[Music]
thank yous for meeting me here yeah of
course you know
he's glad we could set aside our
differences and avoid the war here you
know
so all right salute
no that's too much what are you doing
we're just having a nice little dinner
here all right
well that's just disrespectful oh no not
his hair
and he had good hair yeah you're done
you already messed up
what's going on what are you doing now
this phone no
no no don't go deleting his contacts
he's not gonna know where to answer it
or not
you're finished now that's that's good
look what you did now we were in the
middle of something more today
and now whatever what's going on here
what are you doing oh that's permanent
that's a permanent silly mustache oh now
he looks like a
sleeping musketeer that's adorable but
it's it's ridiculous
he can't he can hardly wash that off
that's it whatever
where you going what is that now what
the what do you do now you're putting in
his hand that doesn't even make sense
here that doesn't even make sense
oh oh andy oh that's hilarious but save
that for a slumber party
all right what do you know you're
rearranging the silverware
that's just so mean it's it's confusing
it's confusing enough what what the
hell [ __ ] hit me don't do oh well you
know the salad you get a little pepper
so that's good that's so that's that's
not so bad
you finally did something constructive
what are you looking for
what are you you're putting the
silverware back that's good well
that's good now he knows he can go from
outside to inside and that's
oh you put a little zhu in his head
that's good yeah
oh now it actually looks better than
when he came in
if he wasn't unconscious he could go out
on the town so that's good
that's good oh look here you all right
white
white barbie's face yeah yeah ain't
gonna get the mustache while you're at
it
cause that's that's the most
embarrassing part oh he doesn't look
ridiculous anymore
oh okay now that's that's now you're
helping everybody
that's good for everybody everybody
likes that nobody wants lettuce on the
floor
all right we done all right you really
turned this around at me
there he's all right and then you garnet
all right
all right he won't even know what hit
him he won't even know that any
oh no no no no no anthony
eddie i can see it in your eyes i can
see it in your eyes you're going the
other way now anthony
and he was going so well well that's
that's
that's perverse here me i don't even
know what what's that what's that what
are you gonna do with that finger
what are you oh yeah no not a wet willy
we're going to war